what the Nobel Prize does is it becomes
a secular Idol you bow down in front of
the king of Sweden and you bow down and
you accept a gilded Graven image with
the Visage of Alfred Nobel on it so like
every religion it has an origin story it
has patron saints and so it has become a
secular religion and sometimes the most
zealous religious adherence are atheist
our terrific guest today is a
cosmologist which as he just told us is
a brch of astrophysics Professor Brian
Keon welcome to triom W it's a great
pleasure and honor to be here guys
thanks for hosing me it's great to have
you on the show before we get into
everything to do with space and
everything that's out there and not out
there uh tell everybody who are you how
are you where you are what's been your
journey through life yeah so I always
like that that uh question that's become
your trademark because it it allows me
to segue into what I always ask people
what's the most important day on the
calendar you know I say what is it and
usually if you're smart and you're a guy
you'll say my anniversary right my
wife's birthday or uh but it's always
some kind of origin story right
everyone's fascinated with an origin and
since I was a little kid I was always
fascinated with not just my own origin
you know which is the only story you
come into that you'll have to rely on
other people to tell you uh the the
truth of what came before but the
universe and what is the ultimate
potentially the ultimate origin story of
all which is how did everything come to
be and it's interesting because what I
do is called cosmology which a lot of
people you know because of the way that
I look and you know my my handsome VIs
uh they no I'm just kidding uh they
think it has cosmetology so you know if
I if I don't get that I get you know or
you're an astrology astrologer whatever
can you tell me my horoscope I used to
say no I used to say no but now I take
opportunity to actually answer it I say
oh you're a Gemini oh that's really
terrible you know you should have that
wart looked at on the back of your neck
there but the these you know the
similarities between both astrology and
astronomy cosmology and cosmetology are
very deep you know emology is very
important
Cosmos means Beauty our face and what I
study is the face that's presented by
the universe to ordinary Mortals to
perceive and it is very beautiful uh and
so I've been fascinated by that on an
aesthetic level and never really
thinking as a kid when I was interested
got my first telescope as a you know
10-year-old little little boy that I
could do it as a job you know who's
going to pay me to be you know like
essentially the equivalent for nerds of
being an ice cream taster or you know a
wizard you know or one of those guys who
you know like test the roller coaster at
SeaWorld so I didn't think you could do
it as a job so I was kind of stying
because I loved it I had this great
passion for it all throughout High
School College in graduate school and
even in graduate school I didn't think I
could do what I'm doing now which is to
be a professor of uh physics and
astronomy at a top university in
Southern California UC San Diego uh
where I get to teach young people and
work with brilliant people that teach me
things about how the universe came to be
and what's going to happen happen in the
Deep future of our existence and so in a
real way I get paid to ask and answer
and and just grapple with the most
fascinating origin story of them all and
that's how did our universe come to be
well that's an awesome uh thing to spend
your life doing it's and I can tell you
love it and you're super excited by it
uh as you know as we sit here recording
this we've just had your friend erk
Weinstein uh on the show and one of the
conversations we part of the
conversation we were having was about
um you know pessimism and optimism and
how we see the future of humanity and
and also how we you know our
relationship with the things that you
study actually our relationship with
things beyond Earth uh and I was saying
that when I was growing up and I imagine
even more when you were growing up
you're 10 years older than I am you know
this idea that our destiny was somehow
beyond Earth was not just universally
accepted it was embedded in literature
it was embedded in culture that's what
movies were about that's what books were
about you know science fiction really
focused it didn't even focus on like how
we going to get to the start that that
was kind of like the a done deal it was
like when we form a society on another
planet here are some of the challenges
or when we have robots here's some of
the moral quandaries that we'll enter
and yet in my lifetime and in yours too
I think that seems to have actually been
rolled back and there isn't anymore that
sense of Destiny and vision and optimism
is that fair to say I I think there is
there isn't uh there's certainly
optimism you know more so than ever in
terms of space and our future being in
space and ironically I'm more
pessimistic about our future being in
space rather than uh you know people
like Eric or people like Elon Musk and
so forth um and we can get into that but
you know it's it's the old saying The
Optimist builds the airplane the
pessimist builds the parachute and you
know who's to say who's more important I
think there's a Temptation because you
sound smart if you're a pessimist and
you sound like just wild ey naive if if
you say oh we're going to be building
these you know like you had Zubin on
last year earlier and uh you know we're
going to be there in 20 years there's
going to be a baby born on Mars and I
love his writing I love what he's said
but I think it's he's totally off base I
mean I think from a practical standpoint
he's off base and yet and yet I think
it's extremely important to contemplate
these things uh for example people uh in
my department uh Shelley Wright very
famous uh uh astrophysicist she's
looking for signals of extraterrestrial
intelligence using uh flashes of light
emitted by potential
lasers you know wielded by
extraterrestrial not in Star Wars but
communicating their presence using it as
some sort of vast internet Intergalactic
Interstellar internet uh I think that
boggles the mind and in fact is is one
of The Inspirations that may you know
spark a young Brian or you know Briana
or somebody now to want to be get into
science which I do think is the most
important thing I think there's no more
important thing and I get into fights
with my colleagues in the literature
Department all the time uh you know that
that you know what is the most important
thing to study do we need more
scientists do we need more Engineers do
we need more you know people in the
so-called stem Fields do we need more
people in the humanities to tell us
about meaning and so forth and so for
that I always look back who are the
people that could do both who are the
people like like our friend Eric Eric
can do both he's one of the most
eloquent well- read historically
intelligent intellectuals public
intellectual talking about you know
Bengali I don't he can speak in Russian
to you he can he can do all sorts of you
know he can do basic uh you know he play
music and uh and it was funny because
you guys were talking about oh like why
do we shame people that that don't play
an instrument I was thinking like I'm
pretty good at playing Spotify that's
about where I end up but but do we need
these two cultures as CP snow used to
talk about I claim let's look back to
the greatest intellects of History read
P pipia by Isaac Newton read Michael
Faraday um uh read read my hero who is
Galileo and you will read things in
there that rival the deepest most
enriching uh poetry in written in Pros
format you think well what are they
they're talking about equations with
like pendulums what does that have to no
because they were speculating on things
there was no there was no science in the
way that we have it today there were no
journals there was no peer review as ER
Eric rails about um and so you would do
things either by live demonstration so
imagine you have this Theory as I'll be
speaking tonight I'm being honored by uh
giving this discourse at the Royal
Institution which is the oldest
continuing dialogue in human in humanity
civilization that never ended since the
early 1800s where speakers come in
they're pushed onto stage and they give
a speech and that's to evoke this notion
that this sciences and evolving stort
it's never finished you never reach the
end of science so when I look at that
and then I I look at farad's writing who
is one of the founding um you know uh
members of the Royal Institution I read
his writing it's poetic and it's humble
and it's beautiful and I say well you
could learn a lot about literature by
reading Michael farad's works on
electromagnetism the invention of the
motor
and thoughts about things that were
speculative uh at UC San Diego I'm I'm
delighted to be the associate director
of What's called the Arthur C Clark
Center for human imagination one of your
great countrymen right uh and Arthur C
Clark and many of his I mean it's it's
incredible Rich language brilliant uh
ideas insights a lot of Technology we
have today uh was pre-aged not invented
by him uh but pre-aged in many of his
books the iPad uh geosynchronous
satellites um a b basis on the moon AI
uh and all sorts of other things that we
talk about today he was talking about
those 50 or 60 years ago writing almost
as a poet and so I feel like to be
optimistic is to think and dream about
these things you know and and reach
beyond what your grasp is as Kennedy
used to say uh but at the same time I
think we can have a little bit uh of a
devolvement into into well let's escape
this place and that's what I'm worried
about so I think we have to balance the
pessimism where you sound really smart
because you can predict the sky is
falling
um and and no one really ever keeps the
receipts you know I actually went back
um and listened to this this podcast by
this guy Sam Harris I don't know if you
ever heard of that but he had on this
other guy Scott Galloway and uh they
were talking about and it was like from
2020 or early 2020 they're talking about
how evil it would be if Trump got
elected because you know God forbid
there'd be a war in the Ukraine probably
and I'm just like wait guys do you ever
look back and and check your predictions
and you know so it's easy to make
predictions about things and come off as
is a pseudo intellectually sound reason
reasoning um but I I think you have to
balance that and humans are awful at
balancing things right we we like
polarization we like going in one
direction or the other we're very
uncomfortable being in the middle
there's an old Yiddish saying that you
stand in the middle of the road you get
hit by both sides of the tra tell us
about it you
guys that being the case do you
sometimes get frustrated at the fact
that we seem to becoming ever more
pessimistic even America the most
optimis nation in the world is now kind
of
pessimistic yeah it it isn't it isn't
when you look at uh things politically I
I was I was you know using with with
Constantine earlier today you know that
when I got into astronomy part of it was
because you know you no one wakes up in
the morning and say I hate those damn
Republican constellations over there and
oh that Democratic comet is going to
save uh we don't think like that it's a
safe space from politics so it's not
polarized it can be there overlays of
that we can get into that um because
everything at some level has some notion
of politization but but that's okay it's
manageable uh I think in terms of
optimism there's kind of this Wildey
thing where you know just take the most
prominent ones that are going on right
now and you guys have had conversations
about this you had some with Eric and
and you've had on others you know it's
AI
depopulation uh and then uh going to
Mars right so those are three very very
interesting and and unique conversation
that you guys have had and when I look
at that and I think well in all those
cases there some element of escapism
which is a fundamental expression of
dissatisfaction with where you are now
but that's not a bad thing right if we
weren't dissatisfied with our lot we
would have never invented at my home
institution the polio vaccine by Jonah
sulk right we would have said okay we
have to live with this or die with this
or not live with this uh Etc so
dissatisfaction is a Hallmark of of of a
civilization the discontent and and sort
of like unwillingness to settle for the
current uh the current Dynamic so I I
think that that is a good thing on the
other hand being too wild-eyed and and
you know just take take the Mars example
going to Mars um is fundamentally I
believe a uh an Escapist you know kind
of fantasy do you think it's pointless I
wouldn't say it's pointless there are
technological benefits that will redown
to any society that Endeavors to do
something on such a grand uh uh such a
grand scale they're actually going to
like yes the project of making the thing
that takes you to Mar will create new
technology and whatever but is there
anything for us on M I guess is what I'm
asking you well um so there there's
something for us right U the question is
is that worth the price you'll have to
pay so I always ask you know Elon God
bless him has 10 kids that we know about
so far yeah I mean what time is it right
um and and I love that I I love his and
he said that you know his he's doing his
part to uh to Forstall population
collapse and I do I do mean that but on
the other hand talking about dying on
Mars to my friend I've had on and you
should interview at some point uh Lord
Martin Ree the astronomer Royal of of
this great kingdom here uh he uh he used
to joke with me that you know his job as
astronomer Royal was to tell the queen
her horoscope but he doesn't do that
anymore sadly she's she's deceased so
the the question is you know he said he
wants to die on Mars and and Lord Reese
would say well hopefully it's not on
impact
right so let's just say it's not on
impact he's going to make it there right
so he's going to get there uh Elon which
of your 10 kids are coming with you
which of you the the sort of pilots on
this craft are not is not at all
possible in my humble estimation for it
to be a return trip I mean the minimum
you're talking about at least the better
part of a decade to to go there do
something there uh return Voyage you
know the way that the planetary orbits
work out the minimum time duration round
trip would be at least two years maybe
even more um all the way you're
experiencing extreme microgravity which
destroys uh your mental Capac capity it
destroys brain function uh astronauts
come back uh their their bodies are
literally as if they've been you know in
a concentration camp wasting away just
there's no no way to exercise see actual
natural sunlight and then once you get
there you're you're it's not like
Christopher Columbus had to bring
civilization with him to the new world
uh or you know that he couldn't find
things to sustain him there now I know
yes there's carbon dioxide on there as
Zubin talked about on this podcast so
carbon dioxide you can use that to make
oxygen and carbon and hey life has a lot
of carbon and oxygen yeah but it's not
like Columbus had to bring with him like
actual seeds so that when he got to the
new world he could start to grow stuff
no there were people living there
watching him discover the new world
right so um but moreover when you look
at the resources that a planetary uh uh
environment can sustain what is it
actually made up of if you took all life
on Earth and all life that's ever
existed so all the biosphere what we
call the biosphere um and you took it
and you you made it into a creamy vomite
likee paste okay how thick do you think
that would be like any every dinosaur
that ever lived every amoeba that ever
lived every chlorophyll molecule that
ever produced inside of these lovely
plants and bushes behind us right how
thick do you think that layer of the
Earth's surface would
beeters you know microns what would it
be any any Francis any ideas I mean I
chomet I thought we were GNA talk about
trometry my favorite tell us how it's
about four millimeters
really that's all yeah and if you've
ever seen the Earth from space like that
that Blue Marble picture you some people
have on your screen sa right you're
looking at you know tens of kilometers
you know millions of times bigger layer
of of you know Sur and even that is the
so-called Thin Blue Line without that we
don't exist right so so just imagine
like taking that that layer of biosphere
that shell of biology and spreading it
on MAR now Mars is smaller it's a little
bigger than our moon a little bit
smaller than the earth um so that would
be a little bit thicker
but can you imagine it I mean can you
imagine transporting that much material
or having unlocking or converting the
carbon dioxide the nitrogen the
phosphorus and DNA and RNA to make a
living biosphere um so why is this
important though why am I not denying
that we should do it uh I question it as
I said I question it on personal as a
father myself um you're a father too
constantly right uh I don't think you're
not not yet ladies I think uh so um
when you when you have a child your
world changes and by the way you don't
have to have a biological child for your
World to Change you can have an
ideological child you can be a father
figure I was an uncular figure for many
years before so so the point is what do
you leave behind to go on this one-way
Journey let's stipulate it's possibly
you could get there maybe even you'd
live um who are you going to bring with
you what what kind of psychological
damage is that going to do to you uh to
leave people behind so I maybe you could
say that just for for um for Elon maybe
he's comfortable with that or maybe he's
not and and he's just so detached from
that sense of reality but I think for
most people it would be very hard to do
that and then let alone to convince
millions of people to do it to create a
sustainable you know agriculture you
know but then why are you going there
what is the reason nobody ask ever ask
him why he says we I want to go there
it's almost like he wants to make this
Arc it's a it's a very sort of almost a
scatological you know like he's making
this Arc Mars is The Arc in in order for
us to be um and the way I've heard him
describe it and I'd love to to talk to
him more about it I don't think he's
talked to a real physicist you know as
far as I can tell uh I don't think Joe
Rogan you know qualifies as a physicist
yet although he's had on a lot of
physicist um but the point being what
are the what are the physical
limitations what what is the purpose of
this well it's to store Consciousness
yes well I say well there are other ways
you can store Consciousness just like
there are other ways you can time travel
do you guys know you can time travel or
right now we're time traveling I don't
mean it like that but uh the the problem
comes in when people want to travel
through time and they want to bring
their bodies with them and they want to
bring the their possessions with them
like some Pharaoh from from you know
from ancient Egypt and so they're greedy
in other words they want to they want to
have their their uh afterlife and and
live it too and I think that when you
step back and realize you are capable
right now or in the future hopefully you
live a long life but you are capable of
living a very long time um and it's not
you know as uh as Woody Allen said I
don't want to live on in the in the mind
of my countrymen I want to live on in my
apartment in Brooklyn uh in this case
it's it's it's through the impact and
the connections that you make on Earth
right now by connecting to People by by
nurturing relationships and establishing
uh the the geometrical explosion of
connection and meaning that comes from
from relationships that's all gone when
you're on Mars you're you're talking
about three other people four other
people if that I mean it might just be
one person right um and so so the
question is what is the goal well where
do Consciousness reside is consciousness
Universal like can you store it on a on
a on a flash drive um you know can we
upload it our AI is conscious I've been
playing around a lot with these uh we
can talk about those and and the
potential I know Eric's expressed you
know some some concerns about them and
others Elon as well um so so what is a
goal nobody ever really gets into well
no I I I mean if I was to steal man what
I perceive as elon's argument is yes
okay you can download the sum of human
knowledge onto a flash drive and launch
it into space where it can be like you
know a message in a bottle for the rest
of Eternity and you could argue that's
Consciousness but it's not
self-replicating right it's Frozen in
Time whereas what he's talking about is
survival of
humanity uh whereby if we all have a
nuclear war here on Earth there'll be
you know seven people on Mars who are
able to reproduce and and and survive on
right so so there's two approaches right
and I agree with you although it is
possible to you know if there there's a
an explanation for the origin of life is
a very mysterious we actually don't know
about it there are people that stipulate
that life you know spontaneously
originated some of the work done uh by
uh late professors at UC San Diego
Miller and Yuri established this
primordial chemistry primordial
earthlike environment and they put in
some goop and they they shocked it with
electrodes and out came you know these
little neander no didn't that would be
pretty surprising uh but it was some
amino acids pre pre pre precursors to
life anyway um it turns out that that
experiment had a lot of um uh incorrect
assumptions about about what the Earth
was like anyway uh the point being that
the the history of the earth is
intimately related to the life that's
inhabited it and actually the life that
4 mimet layer is probably the most
consequential of all the geographic
strata that uh that one would encounter
going you know drilling down to the core
of the earth essentially um and it's a
relic of what we call the anthropos
scene you know when hominids have
existed so the question is does that
encode it you know does just DNA encode
it what level of of hierarchy of life so
is it for Humanity um that of course
again it is a selfish thing right I mean
there's what what would happen if the if
not a nuclear war let's just say the
Earth is hit by some massive extinction
level event that wipes out Humanity well
there there will be other entities that
will live it's it's not like all life
would be obliterated nor did it happen
during the Jurassic period when the
giant Extinction event took out all the
dinosaurs what happened then it allowed
mammals to thrive and flourish and then
we descended from that uh I'm not saying
I I want that to happen by the way don't
get me wrong uh but but the point is
when you put so much into uh this I mean
it's it's not I want to say it's a
fantasy but it is Escapist it's we are
escaping which is a good thing like if
you're on a plane's going down you want
you want that parachute that the
pessimists pack for you right um on the
other hand what's what's the net goal
it's it should be to preserve Humanity
right so would let's say it's going to
cost trillions and whatever amount it is
what if you could put that into another
thing that would Al alleviate the need
for Noah's AR number two in other words
if Elon and put his time and attention
into putting in safeguards against the
main ways that a planet could rid itself
of our presence namely nuclear war um
and some biological War uh or biological
entity like a virus that becomes a
global pandemic you know not that that
could ever happen um so what could you
do to to mitigate those um I think I
think it's far more efficient just just
take one one thing um imagine you go
down to uh to the Pacific Ocean and you
scoop up a bottle of water you guys are
invited come visit me in my podcast in
San Diego and we'll go down to the beach
and we'll scoop up some water from the
there's trillions of microorganisms in
there there's relics and fossils of
coral and all sorts of things in there
if you found that on Mars it would be
the greatest discovery of all time
potentially right um so but that means
something very different like that means
you can find life right now it's in the
ocean and we could could we live in the
ocean maybe not like those guys
unfortunately in the submersible
recently but you can live and and we
already know how to live underwater um
you know there are people in the Navy in
San Diego that do it six months at a
time on a submarine right uh so so the
question is where is the most efficient
use of resources intellectual Capital
human capital why is it why is it that
it's being focused in that direction
towards you know one planet which is you
know admittedly potentially supportable
of you know it's more hospitable than
Venus but but it's less so than than the
ocean do you know what you're reminding
me of there's a did you ever watch West
Wing uh no I never got into that there's
a great scene in West Wing where the the
uh somebody asks one of the staffers at
the White House why it is that we have
to go to Mar I think they're actually
talking about Mars and he launches into
this long monologue about how it's
what's next as in human beings have
always explored they've always taken the
next step they left the cave and they
walked out and then they went to the new
world inverted commer it's and it's kind
of like the idea is that we're an
exploring species right and and that's
what's next and what does that speak of
though I think it speaks of a
restlessness and an unhappiness and with
your current sit it's not like I want to
oh I really can't wait till I can get
away from My Wife and Kids like if
you're happy and and you and you have a
um a network of connections a community
something that you have a deeper meaning
for you know Victor Frankle spoke about
I'm sure you guys have encountered this
you know that that as opposed to Freud
who said that you know the sexual drive
was the strongest innate Drive in
humanity he said no the search for
meaning is and people do anything for
meaning including deprive other people
of their meaning right uh and so I think
it is almost Escapist in a sense and and
and I don't say that necessarily in a
judgmental way I'm just saying be
cognizant of it why are you doing what
you're doing and and I've encountered
that a lot in in science as well uh but
but one thing I just want to come back
to with Mars um and the search for alien
life which I'm very intered
although I'm very pis about as well and
I think some of itates to these very
same topics that would cause somebody
like a musk or anybody who's conscious
and and curious about what it would be
like to live on another planet uh to
think about what are the planetary
astrophysics based limits to things like
climate change like is it possible that
the climate could just run away forever
and we could just keep pumping carbon
dioxide into this atmosphere no it's not
and in fact by studying other EXO so
called exoplanets of which we know
thousands now many of which are exactly
like the Earth in terms of this host
star that they are orbiting around and
and and their density and their average
size um so there's plenty of places
where life could exist and so the
question is well what would it take for
them to get to the same stage that we
had and I always like to point out like
I think you know the key thing is the
key question that I would want to ask an
alien is do you have whales you on your
planet you're like what the hell is he
talking do they have whales on your
planet like why are you asking about
that well you know to get here in this
beautiful Studio to make these beautiful
Neon Lights the these these computers
that are driving the cameras that are
filming Us in glorious 4K right they
weren't built by computers right there
wasn't like some some primordial
computer that sprung into no no no they
were built up for something more
primitive uh and in fact the computer
was built up with transistors and if you
look at what a transistor is the first
one is this thing of like chicken wire
and chewing gun it was really you
wouldn't say like hm now there's 15
billion of them on my single iPhone you
know 14 um but it's true and but it
wasn't built with an iPhone 14 right so
you keep going back and you come to like
light and you come to uh petroleum and
so forth so so whale oil was replaced by
petroleum so that means that for a long
time humans had uh their their lighting
needs met instead of kerosene and
petroleum products by whale oil so like
well how they get how could they have
gotten there from point A to point B
yeah maybe they could have maybe they
could have discovered it and they could
have but but the question is what are
the contingent things the things uh you
know the sinan N without that it makes
the further justification of Technology
uh impossible right so we look at things
like plate tectonics there are theories
that suggest that the biosphere that
existed on Earth is provided a lubricant
that then allowed the plates to move and
and adjust themselves from the Pangia
configuration into the more modern
configuration over a span of just a few
millions of hundreds of millions of
years not a short amount of time but not
not as long as the old as the Earth and
some people believe that's contingent
that we needed to have that in order to
have life exist um so you start putting
together all these different um uh
sequences that had to occur and in the
right order right if you discovered how
do you discover you know the transistor
before you had uh the vacuum tube right
is that Poss maybe it is but maybe it's
not so by asking questions about these
other planets we can then learn about
well what are the unique things about
our own planet and to just go back to
this discovery life thing which I said
you know uh I me you just go down to the
lake and scoop up or the Pacific Ocean
scoop up some some water um we actually
know what would happen the day after
life is discovered uh I bet you guys
think it would be pretty exciting if we
discovered do you know that we
discovered extraterrestrial life on
Earth or it was claimed that we did
didn't this happen during the pandemic
no well did yes yeah yes but also wasn't
there like some back dead bacteria on an
asteroid or something like that yeah I
did read about it yeah yeah so there's
been about eight different recordings of
claims of the discovery of
extraterrestrial life or technology
technology via a signal received from
another solar system potentially or a
byproduct of life in the case of what
was discovered during um the pandemic as
franchis just mentioned the so-called
byproduct of of living creatures called
phosphine which is discovered on Venus
it's been been retracted uh there what
I'm talking about is uh from this very
very famous movie called contact with
with jod Foster so was written by Carl
Sean and his wife Andrian who's been a
guest on my podcast and uh and it was
the only science fiction book he ever
wrote and that book is based Loosely on
an actual figure who another guest named
uh named Jill Tarter who's a leader of
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
well in the
1990s in Antarctica where I've been
twice they' discovered a meteorite and
that meteorites seem to have on it
fragments or portions of
microorganisms either that or or their
respiratory products in other words if
you found like you know exhale carbon
dioxide you have to ask how does it get
there because it doesn't form so easily
naturally um pure oxygen doesn't form
you know so easily naturally so the
question how did it get there well so
there was this huge press conference and
Bill Clinton there's a scene in the
movie contact maybe you guys will cut it
in you guys have such a such an enormous
budget here at this so
lovely good
afternoon I'm glad to be joined by my
science and technology
adviser this is the product of years of
exploration by some of the world's most
distinguished scientists like all
discoveries this one will and should
continue to be reviewed examined and
scrutinized it must be confirmed by
other
scientists if this discovery is
confirmed it will surely be one of the
most stunning insights into our universe
that science is ever uncovered its
implications are as far-reaching and a
inspiring as Can Be Imagined even as it
promises answers to some of our oldest
questions it poses still others even
more fundamental we will continue to
listen closely to what it has to say as
we continue the search for answers and
for knowledge that is as old as Humanity
itself but essential to our people's
future so it wasn't confirmed but it
wasn't this confirmed either for decades
so in other words the general public was
left and that was a real scene that by
the way that was recorded uh and spliced
into a movie about the discovery you
know in this you know white albino guy
looks weird uh it's the whole Narrative
of the book that's fictional but that
one scene is
factual it goes to show you in the mind
of the general public that never was
recanted right you you you guys just
both mentioned two separate claims of so
did those change the world they didn't
change I mean did you guys wake up and
say oh well like all all is restored now
I have meaning in my life because they
discovered some phosphine on Venus and
for all you know they didn't disconfirm
it right I just told you that they it
hasn't been confirmed some people most
people don't believe it's it's valid so
it didn't change your lives so why do we
think you know discovering life on
another planet or going to another
planet is going to find this
Transcendent meaning I I find that it's
it's not entirely self-consistent but
isn't it also about pushing the limits
of what we think human beings can do
isn't isn't that it seeing a
self-imposed limit then going beyond
that isn't that consistent with the with
the human Spirit the drive for all the
the wanting to test yourself push beyond
the limits that Society or what people
think human beings are capable of so I
going to give you one example from from
my country and one example from your
country so 112 years ago there was a
race every bit as viscerally competitive
as the Space Race to land on the moon
which I'll get to to next yeah and that
was the race to reach the Southpole inar
which as I said I've been there twice uh
it's as close to the most boring uh
undeveloped you know Pure White
hellscape of a frozen planet in any
science fiction movie you ever seen you
got there here's how you picture it go
in the middle of the Atlantic Ocean
flash freeze it solid and then look
around you what would you see it's
nothing for 700 miles and yet that was
the goal of a generation of explorers
dating back to world son and Robert
Falcon Scott and they both approached it
amonson actually tried to reach the
North Pole first failed immediately did
a 180 literal 180 and he beat Scott to
the South Pole uh by three weeks and
that three-week period between December
when he reached it and January when
Scott reached it meant the difference
between life and death for the explorers
in Scott's party and the reason they did
that um there's many reasons why the
Brits were doing it on a scientific
Journey so they were trying to they
would encounter things for the Royal
geographical Society they pick up a
meteorite they would find meteorites
there too uh they found you know
petrified seals and but mostly it was
pretty much boring ski trip the other
thing is that the Norwegians were very
comfortable using animals as their
Rockets you know as their exploration
Vehicles driving them knowing full well
that once you got to the top of the uh
South polar Plateau it's about 9,000
feet above sea level which most people
don't realize it's pretty high up um so
they had to ski up over these dangerous
things called crevasses that people
would die in and freeze to death and so
they' SK the dogs would pull them up and
then the way home they don't need the
dogs so what do you think they had you
know for lunch at the top of the world
or bottom of the world they would eat
the dogs the Brits didn't want to do
that so they had to be their own
conveyance animals and they pulled their
sleds which meant they had to carry more
food more fuel more water everything so
it ended up costing them between life
and death that technological decision
that they made which there are some
parallels here so this was reached at
Great cost it was a huge thing people
and you know probably about the
Shackleton voyages these captivated the
world I mean these were some of the most
interesting things the far Horizon go
what's over it um you know that we
didn't go back to Antarctica for over 50
years like in other words they reached
this goal they got there and then they
left and they didn't go back for 50
years and now there's about a 100 people
there in the middle we're talking in the
middle of the northern hemisphere summer
exactly it's the middle of winter at the
South Pole there's about 45 people
that's it for 700 miles you could be
like the richest person on the continent
the fattest person on the you could be
whatever you want on a continent the
size of Western United States it's huge
then now it's fastb another you know
50-year interval which we haven't gone
back to at least we've gone back to the
South Pole that's the exploration of the
Moon first reached 1969 July 20th when
we got there it said we came in peace
For All Mankind really it was a Battle
of Cold War superiority it was a it was
an intellect but in other words people
always talk about the need for human
exploration but really when we point to
it we're really thinking about a a
psychological Frontier more than like a
physical Frontier otherwise why wouldn't
we have gone back to the Moon if it was
so beneficial you know there's helium 3
there and there's you know there's a lot
of uh you know minerals aluminum
whatever maybe not enough to overcome
that kind of what I call the Roger
banister Pro so once Roger banister
broke the for minute mile you know it
became past nobody was really that
interested oh I'm going to be 357 who
cares the banister already did that so
there's this first kind of priority and
what Scott said resonates through to
this day he said great God when he
reached the South Pole imagine you're
coming you know out of the lunar lander
and and Neil Armstrong steps onto a
Soviet Union Flag okay it would have
been the most disappointing thing these
guys had that experience they were
skiing and from the South Pole it's so
flat and so Barren they could see the
Norwegian flag from miles away so they
got there they knew that they had lost
and they still had a make there to say
that they had reached the South Pole at
least as maybe check maybe he was off by
a couple feet no he wasn't scon was
quite awesome at navigation as well he
got there he saw it he said great God
said Scott this is an awful place all
the more so for having reached it
without the benefit of
priority that's the human drive we want
to get there first it's not getting
there getting there so if it was getting
there we would have set up a compound
and done all this cool stuff same on the
moon we haven't gotten back there I
predict the on I I think we can get to
Mars I think person can get there I
think establishing an output is is
almost as uh remote or impossible as
establishing one on the Moon yes I know
Zubin you'll ride in and say that yeah
there's more raw materials there there's
a lot of raw materials in Antarctica I
don't see any civilizations popping up
down there and if you say well like
there's this fallacy that if there was a
nuclear war and God forbid there's ever
a nuclear war I'm not I'm not advocating
King advocates for nuclear Holocaust no
not at all I I treasure this planet and
in fact I'm trying to say we should be
dedicating our efforts towards the
mitigation the milit against the
destruction of the planet but these
idiots who have been given so I always
say the worst thing about physics is
that it produces technology the worst
thing is that we saved the world right
we created the atomic bomb we saved the
world using physics using the laws of
physics nuclear nuclear fion creating an
atomic device we then had the that would
not end even human life on Earth it it
might not be so great but if musk or
others I don't want to single him out by
the way uh because I think it's a very
you know you know generous and
interesting thing that he's trying to do
if misguided in terms of its ultimate
aim because we could establish a human
Outpost in Antarctica that could happen
there's way more resources it's
incredible to make one kilogram to take
this coffee cup into space he's reduced
it from $10,000 to a few hundred do or
it's still you know 80 to 100 times more
expensive than doing the same thing
which I can get Frappuccino down at the
South Pole anytime I want soft serve on
on demand it's incredible so you know we
have to question is that the most
efficient way to accomplish the goal of
archiving and backing up into the cloud
what human consciousness is so your
point is it's a misallocation of
resources in my opinion hey friends just
a short request to ask you to use your
thumb while my thumb is occupied to
leave a like on this video and don't
forget to subscribe it really helps us
with the algorithm now back to the
episode and what should we focusing on I
think the most important thing is
education I think the more stem educated
people we are with a balance of as I
said the humanities in this in the in
the kind of model of a Galileo in the
model of a Newton or any of the great
you know um champions of of science
scientific
tradition if you can couple that with a
sense of I don't want to say Divine
because I think it has a lot of
religious overtones I happen to be
practicing Jew in my case but but in the
sense of that you have to recognize the
limitations of the human ability but
that that's like an enervating A
positive thing that you should say look
we are here for this brief brief amount
of time it it is a flash of the eye how
do we then inculcate our children our
civilization with meaning science is
great for producing technology and so we
come to to expect technology from basic
science um and that's fine if you can
have a steward of that technology that
is competent capable Soulful and
disposed towards the same types of goals
that someone like a musk or or others
are concerned with the preservation of
what is unique and treasured and
beautiful about about human human beings
which I think is our soul or
Consciousness depending on how you
phrase it so I think education in
particular in the stem Fields I I think
that will become more and more important
and harder and harder to replace by
artificial intelligence as well I think
the pandemic showed us that I think the
pandemic what the pandemic showed is and
this rapidly became clear to me as well
is is our own ignorance and I include
myself in this when it comes to science
and medicine and all of these things you
just realize that people who were very
intelligent they have no idea how to
analyze or how to talk about these
subjects without becoming overly
emotional and making choices that were
quite frankly ridiculous in many cases
even even the most educated in some
cases I mean there's a famous quote by
one of my heroes Richard feeman he said
science is the belief in the ignorance
of experts not the wisdom not the
knowledge of experts but the ignorance
of what the hell are you talking about
fman was a genius Einstein was a genius
yeah they were genius because they
doubted what came before them science is
never settled you never never say oh
well this vaccine's 100% effective it's
going to prevent transmission it's going
to cure you it's going to no no
scientist was really okay I shouldn't
say none because a lot of good
scientists did that a lot of scientists
were beh behind it I got vaccinated you
know even I didn't have my kids didn't
get vaccinated I'm glad that they didn't
uh we still have a vaccine requirement
in my University to attend it in 2023 in
the fall of 2023 we still have to be
vaccinated and it's incredible to me and
uh I taught for a long time wearing a
paper mask that I could take off if I
had a sip of my my trusty vodka that I
kept with me at all time uh so so we
became very highly leveraged on science
as a replacement for God yes science is
so powerful I mean you were required to
have faith exactly in the science the
science follow the science no I don't
trust that I don't have faith you know
in Hebrew the word amain which we get in
English as well means Faith or truth
belief I believe I always say I don't
believe in gravity I don't believe in it
I have evidence for Gravity I don't
believe in evolution we have evidence
for evolution why you asking me to
believe and follow and trust and say
this person represents sign no scientist
says that no valid scientist says that
it's doing something political I always
say the problem with you know with with
political science is that it's not
limited to just political
scientists I feel and this is controver
I don't think I've said this elsewhere
but I think that often times scientists
realize we've been given this glorious
script the the book of nature as as
Galileo said is written in the language
of mathematics right uh it's this
beautiful script and yet we're so clumsy
at communicating it because we're never
taught those soft disciplines of the
second culture CP snow spoke about how
do you communicate uh now I I start
doing this with my students it's not
enough that they're they're Way Beyond
me math physics they understand so much
they're so quick they're so they're so
uh they're they're just so impressive my
students uh and and that's the goal goal
you should always exceed you know
Leonardo da Vinci said poor is a student
who doesn't exceed the master um and so
the the notion of of what is science in
terms of the word science from Latin
means knowledge doesn't mean wisdom
that's sa sapian that's where we get
homo sapian what what does it mean homo
sapian means man who knows man who was
wise what is he wise about do you ever
think about this your dog doesn't know
he's going to
die your pet cat doesn't know she's
going to die humans the only species
that know that our time is limited
that's what we know about now where does
that come from that comes from the Bible
we ate from the Tree of knowledge of
life and death of Good and Evil uh okay
you can take it as an allegory but but
the point being we have put so much
faith in science because it's so
powerful because it produces this
glorious technology that allowed us to
communicate and set this up at the speed
of light across continents that are
planetary in scale that we then demand
it and then we say say I don't
understand this just like I don't
understand God uh you know if you're
religious so you tend to correlate
associate a godliness with science but
there's nothing science is amoral it's
not immoral it's amoral look at the most
advanced civilization scientifically of
the past Century where was it not far
from here it was in Germany Germany yeah
I went to the Imperial War Museum the
other day with my children I I couldn't
believe the horrors that you see there
and and the equivalent of what they had
back then
um technologically it was so
sophisticated some of the greatest
scientists in history um uh worked frish
and and others worked uh uh on on the
was later become known as the habber BOS
process and um and Fritz habber was a
German Jew in the early 1900s and he was
very patriotic he wanted to be basically
fully assimilated to German Society he
was known as the father chemical warfare
he invented chlorine gas which then his
Factory uh then became the main
production vehicle for zeyon B which is
used in the concentration camps that
killed his own family members years
later so never conflate knowledge with
wisdom and but that's that's the hard
thing you need wisdom to see who is wise
and and you know Tom says Tomas says who
is a wise person someone who learns from
every person they meet okay you don't
want to be like well my three-year-old
can teach me as much as you know
Professor keing uh but uh but at the
same time wisdom can only be acquired by
experience and when you encounter
something that's never happened before
like a pandemic or nuclear potential
conflict it's very dicey to put so much
power in the hands of someone who may
not be particularly wise and do you
sometimes find that in your own industry
that people think that they have the
answers they think they're all knowing
and all powerful when the reality is
you're a scientist and that's right you
could be brilliant but that doesn't stop
you from being wrong oh yeah some of the
some of and had the benefit to interview
14 Nobel Prize winners on my podcast
it's kind of become one of my trademarks
on the into the impossible podcast and
um and I always like to end it though
you guys have your wonderful question
which we'll get to in a couple
hours and uh and I always ask you know
similar questions but from taken from uh
more a perspective of of almost like a
ascribing meaning to a scientists so
most scientists don't are uncomfortable
talking about you know big picture
things uh we're not particularly
outgoing you know there's an old joke
how do you know a scientist is outgoing
he looks at your shoes when he talks to
you you know then that's how you can
spot him uh but but the point being we
we don't communicate these things to our
students so they're left with this
notion that like well Einstein was
always Einstein no he wasn't he was very
fallible uh fan I just gave you that
quote right the ignorance of experts not
the wisdom of experts um so the best
scientists were are are aware of this
and in fact I encountered this when I
interviewed a man who's become a good
friend of mine a mentor his name is
Barry beish he won the 2017 Nobel prize
for the discovery of gravitational waves
so two black holes 1.2 billion light
years away from the Earth crash together
in This Dance of Death that happened 1.2
billion years ago and these
reverberations in space and time rippled
throughout the cosmos and percolated
throughout the Universe we don't
actually know which Galaxy it was in
eventually it hit the Milky Way galaxy
entered into our solar system entered
into our planet and then hit two
different detectors one in in Louis Iana
and one in Washington State uh within a
few milliseconds of each other
consistent with Einstein's laws of
Relativity and he detected this
reverberation in space and time and I
asked him after he won the Nobel Prize
he was on my podcast and I said uh my my
closing quote is about the the name of
the podcast comes from Arthur C Clark he
said the only way of determining the
limits of the possible is to go beyond
them into the impossible so I always
asked my analog of you know what are we
not asking is um what would you tell
your 20-year-old self
you know what would you tell him or her
to give you the courage to do as you've
done to go into the impossible and he
would say um over you have to overcome
the impostor syndrome especially you
know after you win the Nobel Prize I
said what the hell are you talking wait
you won the Nobel Prize and you have the
Imposter syndrome he goes oh yeah
winning the Nobel Prize made it worse
it's like Barry come on you're you're
one of the most brilliant human beings
that ever lived like you're telling me
you of the impostor syndrome what hope
is there for anybody else he said well
when you win a Nobel Prize you go to
Stockholm you meet the king you eat some
reindeer and you have this FedEd
celebration and one of the things they
do before they give you this you know
giant flavor flave Medallion and uh they
give you a check for your share of the
$1 million purse uh is you sign a log
book and a log book attests the fact
that you received your medallion your
check and your hand painted plaque so
they want to make sure you don't come uh
where's that Nobel Prize that I left
because it's you know 24 Karat
goldplated right so they don't have many
of them so he said he's a curious sort
so he looked at The Ledger and they have
the original Ledger going back to
shortly after Alfred Nobel died in in
1896 um and the first one was award in
1901 so he looks back through the pages
and he sees Richard Fineman you know
pretty amazing he sees Marie curri and
and he stops he sees
Einstein and he goes my heart stopped I
said why he said well you see Einstein
and me a couple of pages apart and our
signatures are there I'm not worthy I
said Barry I've got good news and good
news for you MH I said Barry do you know
that Einstein had the impostor syndrome
goes oh really uh and I said yeah yeah
he had the Imposter syndrome really bad
in fact and I said well and he asked me
who did he have the impostor syndrome
about and he said I told him Isaac
Newton he called Isaac Newton not only
the greatest mathematician and physicist
of all time but the greatest contributor
to human civilization that ever lived
and I said but wait there's
more I said Newton had the impostor
syndrome as well do you guys know who
Newton worshiped the way that Einstein
worshiped Newton one of the Greeks maybe
no no I was to say some like Archimedes
but no no Jesus Christ do you know what
he called his greatest accomplishment
possibly apocryphally hard to verify
this he died a virgin because that was
the only way that he could emulate
Christ he was very religious extremely
devout religious man so he felt that he
was inadequate and impostor before the
likes of Jesus Christ okay that's pretty
good company to feel that about but this
that this is a human trait is a very
good thing and I want to bring this back
because you asked me that scientists
have this notion of kind of superiority
when maybe it's unearned in other words
maybe they're spending kind of The
credibility that the great Titans like
Fineman like the Einstein who did
grapple with I mean Einstein is way more
written about his thoughts on being you
know on Politics on nationalism on
Zionism you know they asked him to to be
one of the first presidents of Israel
and he could have he could have had a
good career if he like just imagine the
fame he could have had if he be uh a
joke uh so so he is way more writings
I'd rather be a
physicist stressful so he has a way more
written word about his um his thoughts
on on God and culture than he does about
physics like by far same with firman but
but the point being uh they married
these two traits of humility with
swagger and that's very hard again
there's an ambiguity it's like we said
before it's easy to follow the left or
the right it's hard to be in the middle
yeah so they could be humble to say as
much as I learn the the battle will be
infinite will never end science like you
you never win science you can win a
Nobel Prize you can get tenure you can
get into a good college or graduate
school you can't win science there's no
end to it it's an infinite game as they
say but on the other hand you have to
also have a little bit of confidence
Swagger that look what you know who is a
man that they can take on the challenge
of unraveling the tapestry of Nature and
the best scientists have that you do you
want to say you go for I was going to
say because one thing that you've been
very interesting about when and when I
read your work you've actually written a
book about this is actually being very
critical of the Nobel Prize and you just
brought the Nobel Prize up now to an
uneducated simpleton like me I think
what the Nobel Prize that's the greatest
achievement possibly human being could
ever have what what's wrong with the
Nobel Prize right yeah there there's
there's a lot wrong with it and there's
a lot right with it and like anything
again we wrestle with ambiguities there
are people that believe uh that abortion
should be completely ille you've had on
Ben shapir he said that right here so no
abortion okay then there have been
people that you've had on um talked
about population to you whatever and
they'll say nope you should it's a
woman's Choice she can do whatever she
wants so uh those are two polls people
cleave to the two polls hard to be in
the middle and say well you know I want
to have this it's like shinger cat it's
Is it alive or is it dead well I
understand when it's alive I understand
when it's dead what is this thing where
it's alive and dead at the same time
this mind-bending notion from quantum
mechanics um that we'll get into for the
the locals get the homework assignments
we give the the quantum mechanics
somewhere um so so the good so is the uh
Nobel Prize good or bad yes it has good
things it has things that are worthy of
of retaining it has things that distort
and um and in some cases destroy how
science is done by putting it into uh
again this conflation between knowledge
and wisdom every four years in America
the New York Times publishes an article
which says signed by 70 Nobel Prize
winners why you should vote for the
president the Democrat who's running for
president never once have these 70 Nobel
Prize winners ever endorsed a republican
be that asn't me maybe they're always
right but then they'll talk about like
genetically modified organisms they
talked about funding for Peter daik at
the Eco Health Alliance they supported
it that he that when Trump tried to
suspend the 70 Nobel Prize winners come
out and do that so they're using this
clout they're using their that what
they've earned rightfully so by their
grappling and wrestling with major ideas
and Science and solving unknown things
and being smarter than I could ever
aspire to be but they're using that to
aine in a political space that's a
danger right because you're now outside
of your lane completely they have every
right to do it not saying they shouldn't
speak about it but someone who studies
the cosmos what do they know about a
treaty with Iran what do they know about
you know what the abortion policy should
they might they they're entitled to it
that doesn't mean they know it what the
Nobel Prize does is it becomes a secular
Idol uh that literally as Barry
confirmed to me you bow down in front of
the king of Sweden wearing Royal regalia
that's required and you bow down and you
accept a gilded Graven image with the
Visage of Alfred Nobel on it uh so like
every religion it has an origin story it
has patron saints it has apostates it
has uh and so it has become a secular
religion and and sometimes the most
zealous religious adherence are atheist
93% of the American National Academy of
Sciences do not actively affirm a belief
in God I'm not saying you know you
should you shouldn't I'm not a theocrat
right but but um but it's an interesting
fact and almost in every case the Nobel
Prize spans these divides between what
uh what you know uh Rabbi salvic used to
call uh the the resume virtues uh versus
the eulogy virtues so the notion is that
uh you should you have things that
you'll put on your your gravestone you
have read about you father son brother
you know whatever scientist uh and then
there'll be UL resume virtues I went to
Brown University Unity Case Western I
got my PhD and then I taught at UC like
I'm not going no one's going to talk
about that you know hopefully when I'm
120 and pass away but no's going to care
where was he an undergraduate like let
me put that on the tombstone no there's
only so much space so I think you know
we but the Nobel Prize will always be
there there's never been a a a eulogy or
something where it's not mentioned for
somebody right so so the question
becomes you know what is it doing to
culture how does it distort the way that
science is done funding for science
you're much more likely to get something
if it's in field where someone's won a
Nobel Prize if your adviser won a Nobel
Prize you're much more likely to win it
um there's historic discrimination that
was present early on against Jews later
against women and other minorities
that's been uh that's been demonstrably
proven it's good and bad do I want it
destroyed no that's why I wrote the book
people get this notion that oh I wrote
the book called losing the Nobel Prize
because I was um I was jealous and
spurned and the sour grapes that I
didn't win the Nobel Prize for this
discovery that I played a huge role in
that was was announced and later
retracted in 2014 2015 that would have
been Nobel worthy had we not been styed
by another Galactic impostor that
masqueraded as a signal we were trying
to see which was the spark of the
universe's first existing moments um but
in reality so they'll say oh you're just
have sour grapes K and you're just you
know I say well look here's the one way
to prove it good news for you you can
prove if I'm uh you know hypocrite or
not get them to offer me the Nobel Prize
if I accept it I'm a hypocrite so far
they haven't but but the point being
I've seen it from the inside I've been
asked multiple times to nominate winners
of the Nobel Prize I've compared it to
what Alfred Nobel requested in his will
and how it's been distorted for purposes
of the vain glory of the Nobel Prize
committee and its and its own purposes
and to the destruction of scientific
colleagues of mine uh and Distortion of
the scientific method in fact so it's
good and bad Brian come back to the
science with me uh because this is the
really fascinating thing so we've talked
a little bit about it but I think the
two big questions that most people have
about space the universe Etc is are we
alone and the conversation that Eric is
very much fond of which is
chemistry imposes very specific
limitations on our ability to get
anywhere in the universe and physics
potentially is able to transcend those
so are we ever going to be able to to
travel in a way that doesn't require us
to essentially burn lots of fuel and ENT
travel in a linear way right uh first of
all yeah so yeah I agree with you those
are two interesting the other one I
always get asked about is you know what
happened before the universe came into
existence right that would be the third
one yeah so that's that's what I get uh
paid you know big dollars from Gavin
Newsome to
answer uh so so to answer the the the
second question that you answered so can
we transcend the limits uh can we
effectively you know uh create a portal
to allow us to travel in finite time
essentially infinite distances there's
nothing that precludes that from
happening but it's been so trumpeted in
things like movies Interstellar you know
all all these things uh the notion of
wormholes and black holes and physic is
associated obsessed with holes come on
guys uh get over yourselves but uh but
the point being if you could essentially
visualize SpaceTime we can't visualize
actual SpaceTime is four-dimensional it
means there's three dimensions up down
right left backwards forwards um we can
visualize that plus time that's four
dimensions if I tell you I want to meet
you in traler did you say traler or trer
I square at exactly 4 p.m. you know
where when and it's up to you how you
get there question is can I fold
SpaceTime you know basically take it
like a piece of paper so we can be out
here at the at the trigonometry uh
podcast you know compound and fold it so
that it would essentially take no time
because CU those two places in space
time in a higher dimensional space so to
do that you have to fold it into another
dimension right you have to fold it from
the two-dimensional analogy into into
the third dimension and put them next to
each other the question is that possible
all we can say is there's nothing that
precludes that from happening but we
have no evidence that that's even
possible so the theories that Eric and
others have worked on rely on things of
having multiple extra Dimensions more
than four less than 20 and that may seem
like well you know who cares it's less
than a those can be very well
rationalized why it's say 10 or 11 uh in
Eric Theory versus say four that we
observe today but I should say there's
no evidence for it so the first thing
then what I like to talk about when when
I'm with Eric is what are some of the
ways that we could verify not the actual
existence of either strings other
subatomic You Know M micr Atomic level
or extra dimensions on a grander scale
in his in his model of geometric Unity
um but are there testable traces
vestigial relics of those models that
can be tested at the relatively low
energies that we have accessible on
Earth or at the most powerful Cosmic
accelerator of all which was the Big
Bang which is what I study so there will
be relics just like right
now in this glass of finest vodka uh
there are molecules of hydrogen and
oxygen the hydrogen in here came from
The Big Bang this is an artifact of the
big bang that I'm holding right now in
your body they're artifacts of the Big
Bang the oxygen came much later from a
generation of stars that very you know
um very almost scatological sacrificed
themselves blew up became uh and their
byproducts became the oxygen in here
that's basically it right um so there
are relics that have traveled through
time and we can study the composition of
this and ask actually in here if we zoom
in real tight and I know your crack
animation team will do this to justice
that I can only dream of but if you zoom
in every so often about one in a few
million particles of of water in here
molecules of water have a hydrogen
molecule that has an extra Neutron so
you guys know because this is the one
the second most aidite podcast in all of
existence after my podcast uh that uh
hydrogen has three isotopes that means
they has two different numbers of
neutrons so there's a hydrogen which is
a proton then there's a proton plus a
neutron that's called dyum then there's
a proton plus two neutrons otherwise
they're chemically identical you can
drink it I have videos on my channel
where I make it into ice and I drink it
and this glass has a ratio of tridium
and dyum and ordinary protonic water
that is exactly predicted in the theory
of cosmology known as The Big Bang
nucleosynthesis so that is a vestigial
relationship but just this glass of
water we could go in the laboratory next
door and measure it that means we could
prove the Big Bang can we do the same
for string theory can we do the same for
what's called Loop quantum gravity can
we do the same for Steven wolfram's uh
physics project Eric Weinstein's
geometric Unity can we do that are there
any first we have to answer those
questions so yes the we're a long way
off from from motivating it it is is
nice to think about the most concrete
thing we can say is there's nothing that
forbids it but is there any evidence for
it that's not so clear then it sounds
like your answer is so far there isn't
there isn't and there's definitely no
evidence for it but there's also no
evidence for string theory as Eric
talked about and that's garnered a lot
more tension time and money all right
are we alone in the universe I've always
been persuaded by the pure statistical
argument that given the scale of it
there's bound to be and you mentioned
yourself you talked about there's loads
of planets and the goldilock Zone all
around the universe surely there's
intelligent life somewhere out there
right statistically speaking right so so
I like to make the the following analogy
so I believe that there's no intelligent
life in the universe well especially I
mean especially on this planet that's
right this this planet's all the the
worst except for all the others um so uh
I believe that we become very uh
enamored of this notion again there is
some primordial Beauty to the notion of
escaping and thinking about things that
transcend our limitations of time or
space or existence and one of those is
the existence of other life forms that
may exist in in the universe first of
all we can say there's zero evidence for
such life forms even a slime mold on
Enceladus you know in our own solar
system there's no evidence for it and
that's important because uh there is a
concept purported by the man who coined
the term Big Bang actually you guys are
the perfect people to ask this I've
never gotten a straight answer is Big
Bang a dirty word is it a dirty phrase
no no no cuz supposedly Hoy Fred Hoy sir
Fred is one of the greatest astronomers
in history he coined the term Big Bang
as a pejorative meaning orgasm H so
that's never said in this country we had
a better sex life
than uh no I didn't know that no I I
don't think nobody would he was a
proponent of the steady state model uh
but but in any case he uh the he also
came up with a notion of what's called
pans spermia can I say that on the show
whatever you want it's a free speech
show it's a free speech and great so the
notion of what's called p spermia it
means that uh that there will be
exchange of material between planets and
between other St star systems in our
galaxy and that will potentially uh be a
an almost like a Noah's Arc for life to
transport it doesn't solve the origin of
Life problem but it could potentially
solve the uh abundance of Life problem
in our solar system or how how did it
come here he claimed it could have come
from another another planet uh not too
far away by Cosmic standards so it gets
here now I actually have some of this
and as we said these meteorites and so
forth that are found in Antarctica it's
well-known phenomena I actually have a
tiny piece of Mars it doesn't have any
amino acids or DNA or a little uh green
men on it but it comes from Mars and we
can prove it comes from Mars uh just
trust me we have it from many other
bodies in our solar system so why is
that important that means that things
can come here well guess what that means
that things can go from the earth out
there right so you have to answer the
question what is the probability and
what does it say about life in the
universe that we haven't found life say
on Mars now Mars is a big place and yeah
if we went somewhere on Earth but almost
everywhere on Earth has life almost
everywhere even Antarctica where I've
been Antarctica is 17th of the total
number of continents on this planet it's
about the size of Australia uh so it's
pretty it's pretty big there's almost no
life there though there's almost no
there is life there's microbial life
there are these giant birds called skuas
uh that will like take a toddler away if
the toddlers were allowed on on the
continent or not um and then there lies
a couple Penguins on the coast that's
about it there's no polar bears or
anything like that um and then there's
humans so you're talking about you know
this vast continent the size of
Australia hundreds of times big or you
know tens of times bigger than the UK no
life almost no life but if you make the
argument that life should be abundant
based on statistical probability as fery
did en Rico fery one of the greatest
physicists he created What's called the
fery Paradox there's so many planets
there's so many gold they didn't know
about the goldilock Zone back then but
they said if uh if the average lifetime
of a technological civilization is even
a million years then just in the age of
our galaxy which is which is maybe 8
billion years or more uh that means we
should have been visited by thousands
and th even going at a slow chemical
rocket speed so he asked the famous
question where are they so we have to
ask where are they and and come up with
solutions to that firmy Paradox and
there are many purported solutions but
one of which is there are no aliens
right I mean the most simple thing based
on evidence is that there are no
certainly technological civilizations
that we're aware of there could be
beyond what we're aware now the best
calculations do the following they don't
say and as I don't say I don't say
there's no life I say the probability is
very small uh and certainly even smaller
for technological life it has to be even
smaller right if there's a dolphin
swimming on a on a pool in Enceladus
we're never going to know about it
because it doesn't have an iPhone to let
us know that we live there unless we
stumble upon it right so it has to be
technological how do we get to that
technology comes back to what we said
before we start with primitive things
maybe are hydrocarbons necessary is
global warming a a trademark a Hallmark
of civilization some say it is in other
words we should look not for uh
Transmissions of you know I Love Lucy
but we should look for global warming on
another planet so far we haven't seen it
doesn't mean it doesn't exist but that
would mean terraforming and and
modifying the the that particular
climate then did they have a biosphere
did they have chlorophyll do they have a
great oxidation event do they have a
Jupiter that sucks up deadly asteroids
from impacting the the Earth or whatever
the analog Earth is in the goldilock
zone that's not in the goldilock zone do
they have a moon that's at the exact
right distance to create tides that can
cause chemical intubation almost between
uh life Land and Sea uh do they have
plate tectonics that we talked about are
those plate tectonics lubricated by
these microorganisms so there's many
different hurdles and the way I like to
say it is so you can phrase it like this
imagine that there were eight things
that had to happen for us to have this
conversation under these Lights and
Camera right there had to be a big bang
you there had to be uh the formation of
matter from no matter so people think
that matter is conserved it's not energy
is conserved but matter is not then
there had to be primitive elements that
could support life then life had to come
about and be conscious then that life
that was conscious had to create
technology and so for so you just go
through and you say like this and then
there had to be things that prevented it
asteroids there had to be dinosaurs that
got that were there but got killed off
and fossils and so you say there's eight
of them and each one has a probability
of one in a th that's it just say one of
a thousand that there's a big bang
whatever that means one of a thousand
that there's a Jupiter one of a th and
we know the probabilities are much much
much much much lower let's just say for
the sake of the argument one divided by
a th000 there eight of those you take
one over a th you raise it to the eighth
power you get one and 10 to the 24th
that same number is the inverse of the
number of planets we think there are in
the observable universe's history so
over 13.8 billion years we think there
have been 10 to the 24
which is a trillion trillion planets
that could be life inhabiting but the
probability I just said is one in 10 to
the 24 so that so the problem comes
about the human mind is incapable of
multiplying a zero by an infinity and
that's why the statistical argument I
think is a a very crude but often
overestimate of the probability or
possibility of Technology the emergence
of life on Earth is so ridiculously
unlikely that's right that for that to
be replicated anywhere in the universe
even with the number of planets that
exist is still extraordinarily unlikely
because it was so unlikely that it was
formed here yeah and there's so many
contingent things that have to occur in
just the right order which brings us
inexorably to the final question of the
three that you always get asked yeah
which is about where life comes from
yeah so I I think that where everything
comes from where everything comes from
yeah so right now is an interesting time
because throughout history you know if
you took a a pingpong ball and you put
it in a bag and for for each year that
human civilization has existed uh say
going back 5,000 years uh the very first
cosmological models in the Bible and
ancient Egypt and and Su Samaria and you
wrote on it what's your model of the
universe like is it Eternal is it
cyclical is there a turtle on top of a
turtle is there a uros eating its tail
what is it just just put it in there the
overwhelming number of ping-pong balls
would have a static Eternal Universe
Einstein believed in it Newton believed
in it it's interesting the Bible does
not believe in it the Bible has a
creation event right uh there are
Egyptian myths that have a creation but
most models and most people for all time
believed that the Universe was static
and in fact the name that we give static
meaning it exists has always existed and
will always exist as it is exactly 100%
right so uh and why do we know that well
we're sitting on this thing called a
planet I don't know if you know any
Greek my Greek's not that strong but
Planet means Wanderer well why do we
have the name it's like Jews we we talk
about people that aren't Jewish we we
call them goam or you know which just
means Nation it's not like a put down or
anything um but that's interesting
because like we're only 0 2% of the
population of the world right so we're
like we have a name for the 9 like just
call them people and like we're the
weird ones right but but anyway uh so we
have a name for these things that moved
they're called planets well why were
they special because they were the only
things that moved everything else is
static it looks like it is unchanging we
know the stars move a little bit but you
couldn't perceive them over human life
tongue but the five planets that they
could see back then after which our days
are named and so forth there's deep
inculcation of astronomy in our daily
lives we just take for granted but but
anyway um those things move and so it
was natural to suspect as Newton did as
Einstein did um that the Universe was
static and eternal uh and that prevailed
for an extremely long period the
preponderance of human history and so we
asked the question of what could
overthrow that well before I would say
the last decade it was impossible to
speculate any more than just purely
qualitatively but now with telescopes
and tools like that of my team uh that
my team and I are working on called the
Simon Observatory and other competitor
teams we're looking potentially at a
relic just like these water molecules
reveal the fiery Fusion conditions that
were present in the first second after
the big bang we're able to go 30 orders
of magnitude farther back in time and we
will reveal the presence via what are
called gravitational waves those
gravitational waves would originate from
a Quantum a purely Quantum phase of the
universe's history called inflation okay
what what does any of that mean okay so
the universe the question is did the
universe come from what's called a
singularity or not was there a point of
infinite temperature infinite density
infinite energy from which all the
matter and energy that we're
experiencing today came from including
the molecules in here including every
cell in our body the matter of that so
forgive me I'm just trying to make it
simple enough that it is like me can
understand hopefully other people
watching can understand as well so the
idea of the Big Bang is you have this
matter that is I'm I'm using very stupid
language I'm aware but it's super
condensed absolutely that's and then it
explodes and cools over time and that's
how you get the universe so it's either
that yeah or or a static Universe there
are actually other more than one pos
other alternative yeah it could be that
there was a preceding universe that had
a big bang in Reverse called a big
crunch it could be that there are
multiple universes that exist parallel
to ours of which we're just one that has
properties features and phenomena
consistent with the existence of
cosmologists and podcast and people
right so we want to know is our universe
in accident yeah is it a fluctuation a
fluke and using technology for the first
time we can confirm that we could
potentially reveal that our universe did
in fact begin not only with a
singularity with a point of
incomprehensible hellscape like energy
density pressure everything you could
imagine but it would also reveal the
presence of what's called a
Multiverse just as cernus and Galileo
showed that the Earth is just a planet
it's not the center of the universe as
people had thought for thousands of
years back to Aristotle and beyond that
the Universe was centered on the earth
because that was the natural place for
it to be no they disproved that they
conjectured in the case of cernus and
proved in the sense of of Galileo
eventually Isaac Newton no but there's
more than one planet there's more than
one star there's more than one Galaxy
there's more than one cluster there's
more than one super cluster of galaxies
why not more than one universe and in
fact concomitant with the singular
origin of the universe comes the
Multiverse so in other words you almost
cannot have a single Singularity a big
bang without having a Multiverse they're
almost wetted at the hip so the stakes
are very high because that's very in you
know it's very incompatible with say
biblical narratives or it's incompatible
with a lot of philosophical uh
speculation that you could have parallel
multiple universes in fact they may not
be even distant from us just like they
may be in very closely related to us or
they may be us in the sense of what's
called many worlds Multiverse
interpretation so the stakes are very
high it's the most primitive thing this
is why I'm so interested this is why I
do what I do because to study where
everything came from
where potentially as Steph Hawkings said
asking what came before the Big Bang is
meaningless as asking what's north of
the North Pole he may have been wrong
surprisingly uh he may have been wrong
no it would be very interesting I asked
I would say to ask God if God exists to
say what happened on the Tuesday before
the Big Bang that may have an answer for
the first time in history by technology
that my colleagues who are far smarter
than I am are helping to build via
What's called the Simon observator which
is located it's actually one one of the
if not the highest altitude construction
project in the world building a massive
telescope
array $30 million project funded
primarily by the Simons foundation in
Manhattan New York and this is to
unravel what caused the bang was there a
big banger or was it all a spontaneous
fluke and if it was a big bang are there
other universes parallel to ours in a
sense I think you know for me it's one
of the most exciting things to Grapple
with when are we going to find out well
if you join my
webinar uh so the the challenging thing
is that these things take time we're
almost done with construction we have
colleagues that are there right now in
Chile this is in the otom desert 5200
meters above sea level 17,000 feet above
seal as I said highest observatory in
the world highest construction project
in the world higher than you know the
base station permanent base station
amount Everest very challenging
conditions uh very low oxygen extreme
ultraviolet damage from the Sun uh but
it does make you know it's compared to
going to Mars it's like a cakewalk so
Elon is welcome to spend some time there
active volcanoes next door to us um and
uh it's a very uh inhospitable place
we're delayed by the pandemic a year and
a half two three years which cost money
because you can't just say well I know
you're going to get your PhD working in
the keing laboratory come back in two
and a half years when things are you
know no we couldn't do that so we kept
it going cost more money and luckily
we've been able to see it through so yes
we're we're about to get what's called
First Light when we'll get the first
astronomical data later this calendar
year 2023 and then we should have
results a year later but what I always
caution people is that we won't be able
to say definitively we won't be able to
say yes there was definitely a
singularity you could however say that
there was no Singularity other words you
can um in science you have to be careful
most people think it's like math you can
prove 1 plus 1 equals 2 you can prove
you guys know this that uh you know sign
is is opposite over hypoten right
trigonometry isn't that right you guys
know any okay you can prove those things
mathematically such an optimist yeah I
know it goes back to uclid uh uh right
so you can prove those you can't prove
something in physics you can't prove
that the you know the Big Bang H but you
can rule out the other Alternatives and
so therefore you can falsify things
about alternative models so by
discovering the pattern that we're
searching for we would not prove the
singularity but we'd falsify the
Alternatives including some purported by
Nobel laurate and Friend of of mine and
your Countryman sir Roger Penrose who
has a model that's a cyclical universe
that Cycles into and out of existence so
I always say my job is to not prove
theories it's to kill theories prove
them wrong and I think that's where it's
nice to kind of marry the the
theoretical with the experimental and
hopefully we unveil new knowledge about
the origin of the only story that had no
precedent
perhaps that is absolutely fascinating
Brian and the one question question that
I want to ask before we finish up is
this when you see people whose knowledge
of science is so completely arai let's
take for instance something like a flat
earther do you think it's a fault of the
individual or do you think it's the
fault of science H that's a good
question I first would say it's the
fault of Education because it's very
difficult although I should say you guys
are you guys are very good at you know
self-mocking Behavior but uh but I know
that's I know because I'm a big fan of
yours that you guys are highly
intelligent it's a British thing yeah
you can't pretend to be smart here
otherwise people beat her out that's
right Bic let's stipulate that I want
you to be honest and now we're getting
all Diary of a CEO and you guys which
you know you guys are going to who that
di comp so I'm going make you guys you
guys got to be real London real no I
don't say that guy either um could you
guys prove the Earth is is a sphere no
you couldn't right no so imagine proving
that the Earth is not the center of the
solar system right and imagine proving
the solers is not the center of the G
anyway um so why is that you guys are
educated people can you imagine saying
ah you know I never read Shakespeare oh
I can't spell you know I mean my spell
checker gets a lot of work but you would
never be comfortable with that so it's a
little bit on you guys right an educated
man or woman in the 21st century should
know some of the classics it's it's like
I you know yes we can cancel anyone you
want but but to not know it it's
canceling yourself right if you don't
know these if this doesn't bother you
like how do you know that the Earth is
going around a giant B Fusion reactor
called the sun um so part of its
education because it's hard right people
the teachers don't learn it they're not
forced to do it and so they don't teach
the students but also the Curiosity of
the individual has to be important and
one thing I have I'm not great at math
I'm not the greatest at building exper I
have rapacious curiosity and I think
that's the trait that has allowed me to
achieve the mod of success that I've had
because I keep wanting to answer these
questions cuz I keep realizing how
finite my life is so I would say you
know flat earther is just you know is a
byproduct of this unless it's people
that you know much more passionately
believe that aliens not only exist but
are actually visiting you know parts of
California and parts of Virginia and
I've had a lot of conversations about
that on my podcast and we'll continue
because I think it's interesting uh
potentially because it would open a
portal to you know learn about physics
of a different Century but be that as a
thing so to answer your question Fran I
do think it's partially on the
individual
partially on the society that's
producing the individual that giving us
so much potential technology byproduct
of basic science that nobody understands
well I think that's kind of it isn't it
because I think the the world has come
to a point where it's so complex and so
complicated uh I don't know if if you
could you you may be able to uh my
grandfather could maintain his own
vehicle right very few people can do
that now and it's not because
necessarily people have got Dumber it's
because the vehicle has got more
complicated that's right yeah I think
the same is true of there are so many
things you now have to know to survive
or to thrive particularly that the
amount of time you can spend learning
certain things most people simply aren't
going to be able to dedicate that much
time to that particular thing on the
other hand technology takes away with
one hand as you're saying the ability to
change a battery in your phone yeah good
luck with that um let alone you know
service the CPU on your car but um but
it gives too right now with uh with chat
GPT with artificial intelligence which
we'll talk about some other time that
when you guys come on my podcast
hopefully in Southern California uh we
can tell you all about physics man yeah
exactly sort you out wa tell them about
the multiv sit down Bri right cuz it's
we're going to be a I'll win the Nobel
Prize next um so as an example like I'm
kind of glad that I wrote my first three
books without the help of AI because I
know I did it myself it's provable I
could do it it didn't exist but now that
that also has become a lever and a force
multiplier for me cuz now I can do stuff
where I can actually take uh say the
written works of Galileo who is one of
my heroes I said I was able to get his
written words and create the first ever
Audi book by Galileo it's kind of weird
you think oh there's audio no no one had
ever done that I did it I read it uh
with with Carlo relli who's a famous
physicist um and uh and Lucho pillo and
a couple of Nobel Prize it was amazing
thing well now I can say hm I can take
that text I have the document file put
it into a large language model then I
can start to say well what would Galileo
say about the Multiverse and I've made a
Galileo chatbot I've made a fine bot
I've made an Einstein bot and so I'm
doing this exploring because the
question is can they then derive new
laws of physics so the people who will
win in the AI age are not the people are
like gifted with this innate abil who
has an inate ability to program in
Python you know with with a you know
JavaScript rapper nobody knows how to do
that but you might not need to like I'm
not a great programmer but now I can
tell Bard or chy write a a python rapper
around this this model that I get and it
will start to I can ask Gallo what do
you think about quantum mechanics I can
do mind and then I could say well here's
all these data points from the spectrum
of an exop planet and here's 10,000 of
those here's a thousand simulations of
what life could be like compare those
and I could never have done done that
you know 20 years 10 five years ago so
technology is giving us abilities that
we never had but what's the key thing
you have to be curious about it I can't
teach curiosity I can stimulate it I can
avoid it and as Barry barish the same
Noble La I told you about he said we
have almost a negative association when
I say curiosity killed the cat we that's
a bat like I don't want to kill a cat
like you murderous you know Peta
violator right so so it's almost a
negative thing curiosity is the most
beautiful unique human Advantage so when
you have a child or you have your
ideological children that that that you
support and you Mentor inculcating
curiosity that's a superpower that's all
we have that's our that's our Clause
that's our teeth as human beings so
that's what I would want to inculcate
most of all well I agree with you but
then we come into conflict with I
suppose what we were talking about at
the beginning which is the Curiosity to
explore right I suppose it's different
when it cost you trillions of dollars
right and come back with me cuz I I want
to finish that conversation actually or
at least do more on it which is you
mentioned education but stem education
will only produce more scientists and
more engineers and and so on who will
want to go to Mars right so I my sense
from what you're saying is that you you
think that a lot of the way we think we
want to use science to to fill a void
that actually gets to be filled by other
things while we're here down here on
Earth a lot of that is is I would agree
with I would say that there's a there's
a meaning Gap yes that can't be filled
by technology and it can only be filled
ironically by reverence for the past so
in other words when you think about um
you know like the the worship of the
young that we have nowadays Tik Tok the
Instagram Snapchat and and and even with
these AIS and Stu like just like every
second on Twitter it's like some new get
rich I can't keep up with it or like
follow these 10 tips and you'll get AI
um and before that was web 3 Bitcoin we
goes on and on and so there's this
Future Shock that older people feel
um and yet we are the only repositories
of wisdom I say we you know I'm older
than you guys right but but the point
being that you have to have a reverence
and and in the age where you kill God
there's no reverence for who cares about
some book that was written 3200 years
ago had even if it was written by God
whatever it's out of day but certainly
it was written by man like it's totally
irrelevant like I have the scene in my
book where I kind of you know take down
the Nobel Prize through most of the book
and try to build it up towards the very
end because I think if it doesn't get
reformed if we have more joke Nobel
prizes or things that are it's going to
collapse under its own weight you know
the Pulitzer Prize used to be way more
prestigious you talked about this in
Michael mice and like the polzer prize
used to be really prestigious um now
most kids don't know what a polzer prize
is but the Nobel Prize people still the
same danger can befall the Nobel Prize
if it's not reformed in the way that I
hope and my and it's not the reforms I
present are not the but anyway so I
decried this I I write that in
2016 2017 I finished the first draft of
the book Ed the publisher and a Nobel
laurate came to UCS to give a talk
Duncan H day and he was a Brit and he
was at Princeton he actually did the
work that one of the Noble Prize at UC
San Diego where I am and uh he brought
his Nobel Prize with him I was like this
is weird and after his talk people went
up to it and were kissing it people were
taking selfies of it somehow it ends up
in my hand I took a like I just written
a book and I remembered back to the
scene from Exodus in the Old Testament
and the Jews get LED out of Egypt by
Moses through a split sea after 10
deadly plagues and it's all super
ridiculous miraculous and then they get
to the other side and they don't have
water for a couple days and they start
to complain they're like oh why did you
take us out of Egypt were there not
enough graves in Egypt that's like
classic Jewish humor like then they
start complaining about the food in
Egypt we had garlic and cucumbers I'm
just like what the hell like we think as
like idiots and then 40 days later after
that they build golden calf worship it
and they say this is the god that led
you out of Egypt that they were just Led
Out was 40 days ago in other words the
attraction to idolatry is very very
strong in human beings we can't
comprehend what it was like I mean Rabbi
once told me was like the sexual urge
and a man you know straight or gay right
it's like it's almost overpowering we
have to control that as good men and
Society right um and that was what it
was like to worship but we still worship
idols wealth education Prestige
followers uh ratings adverti all these
things we still we're just as idolatrous
as ever how would we know that well we
have to go back and read and and have
some connection and reverence for wisdom
not I'm not saying let's look at the
technology of the 32nd Century no I'm
way I'm in love with technology but it's
addictive and it's worshipful it's
dangerous because it becomes a false
idol and that's well the second
commandment we're warned against that
and one of the things I'm hearing in
that which I find very interesting is we
confuse knowledge with wisdom and we
think because we live in a world where
all the knowledge of the universe is at
our fingertips that means that all the
wisdom of the universe is at our
fingertips that's right when maybe it's
not that's absolutely not right and even
going back and reading great literature
not not only reading the Bible reading
you know the great literature of of
civilization and and asking yes what can
we do with that and the conflation of
that you you know the old joke that you
know knowledge is knowing a tomato is a
fruit but wisdom is not putting it in a
fruit salad you know it's there's some
truth to that uh but but never more so
when we think that you know I I happen
to think again we keep talking about Eli
I think he's very smart I don't you know
he may be wise I I haven't met him I
haven't talked to him but just as I said
that one thing the one question the
first question I would ask him is who
are you going to leave behind I don't I
don't think I think he is a good father
I see him pictures with his with a
little ex and whatever as a as a man as
a
father is that what you're willing to
give up like why how how will you
explain it to him because you're not
going to take him so those are the those
are kind of the questions um you know
that that I'm most curious about and so
that's where I want to get knowledge is
cheap knowledge can be found anywhere
Wikipedia knows way more than any of us
will ever know but wisdom is extremely
precious and it's highly highly
undervalued asset unique to to human
beings now that is a good point to
finish on Professor Brian keing as
always the last question we ask is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about that we really should be as a
society I think the the preciousness the
uh the fact that we're likely alone I
think it inspires Terror and I think
things that terrify people there's a
book by Ernest Becker the denial of
death we don't like to think about it we
build monuments we build pharaohs and
sarcophagy and pyramids we build Nobel
prizes we do all these things to mark
this little speck of a DOT that we
inhabit when inter meeting is available
to everyone no matter how wealthy or
poor you might be and I think developing
those connections to me and putting at
risk the potential
consequences of personal
Devastation and it seems ironic I'm
advocating that you should be vulnerable
to Devastation no no no because any of
us that are parents can contemplate in a
nanc the most devastating thing that we
can imagine I won't even say it it
brings me into tears to think about it
but every parent has it every parent has
it I don't you and I are just beaming
this back we know what we're talking
about I don't have to say a damn thing
and you you know what we're talking
about too but that's a very powerful
guide poost it's telling you lean into
those things what's important that if
taken away would devastate you I don't
think we like to talk about that and I
think that and thinking in that way of
bridging gaps and maybe you know not to
make this you know too Lex Freedman is
but to to to bring this interpersonal
connectedness that we are part of this
vast network of
humanity uh that will bring love this
nature of distribution of love because
every person you add to a network it
increases geometrically and
exponentially make those connections
make the deepest connections such that
if they're taken away you can't Envision
what life would be like lean into those
that's what we should be talking about
that's really valuable I appreciate that
Brian